de la bonne humeur de bons camarades
voilà l'atmosphère de la colonie en
dehors des moniteurs il y a dans les
colonies un personnage qui a beaucoup de
travail c'est le cuisinier mais il ya
aussi les jours de grandes fêtes lorsque
toute la colonie se transforme en
kermesse
et c'est gagné d'autres encore
participant à l'épreuve difficile qu'est
la course des garçons de café mais j'en
connais qui ne recule pas à l'idée de
ville et une assiette de crème sans y
mettre les mains
quant au fond de gamelles de chocolat ce
sera la muse en démonstration des
gourmands impénitent et ses activistes y
et permettront de ramener à la maison à
la fin des vacances les oeuvres
personnelles qui sont plus apprécié que
les habituels cadeaux touristique et le
soir le feu de camp traditionnel avec sa
gaieté ces jeux d'ombrés de joie scène
de nouvelles amitiés et de force 9
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]